[Musique]
l'esprit humain
a toujours été familier avec la notion
de l'espace pendant longtemps les hommes
pour se déplacer ou se référer à surface
de la terre regarde les astres dans le
sien
aujourd'hui encore
milliers d'applications gps embarqué
dans le téléphone je sais que c'est pour
certains pour venir ici peut-être que
vous avez utilisé google maps
mais aussi des applications embarquées
dans nos ordinateurs dans nos voitures
ou simplement des sites web basés sur la
localisation fonctionne grâce à des
satellites dans l'espace
je m'appelle richard
je suis un ami
les ovins j'ai récemment découvert que
la combinaison de la technologie
géospatiale et l'analyse de données à
grande échelle
que d'aucuns appellent big data
analytics est l'un des moyens les plus
sûrs pour trouver des solutions durables
aux défis de notre époque
mais
avant de vous amener dans cette aventure
spatiale et de découverte de données je
voudrais vous présenter deux personnes
la première personne que je voudrais
vous présenter et c'est andré
andré qui est aussi présent dans la
salle avec nous
après avoir étudié le droit à
l'université de lomé pendant deux ans
a découvert sa passion pour les
nouvelles technologies
il avait à l'entreprise d'apprendre à
coudes et tout seul jusqu'à devenir
développeurs d'applications web et
mobiles
il a ensuite travaillé sur des projets
d'envergure notamment à la
digitalisation du système de micro
finance pour le compte du gouvernement
de la république du bénin
andré aujourd'hui le responsable des
opérations technologiques et african
jazz passeur intelligence agency
pour moi entrer c'est la représentation
parfaite du monde de l'innovation
technologie la deuxième personne que je
voudrais vous présenter c'est ma mère
après six mois
mais rien cette dame quand vous pouvez
voir et là tu fais peut être at ellis
sais pas comment mais ça va bien on
s'entend très bien
commerçant pendant longtemps à lomé
maman finalement découvrir sa passion
pour l'agriculture
elle a donc retourner au village où elle
gère aujourd'hui notre ferme agricole
maman cultive du maïs du manioc du
piment
et beaucoup d'autres produits quel faux
bond au marché local
pour moi moment est la représentation
parfaite du monde du développement socio
économique
messieurs tu de l'autonomisation de la
femme
mais il souffre aussi de près je me suis
rendu compte que j'étais à
l'intercession de cette demande dont je
viens de vous parler
et en plein air et sert désormais de
faire le pont et a dit m innovation
technologique au service du
développement socioéconomique
c'est encore enfant j'ai connu le
privilège de l'agriculture il faut le
disait en premier league
beaucoup ici non pas pratiquer
l'agriculture n'est ce pas donc pour moi
c'est un privilège
on était vraiment libres ont été heureux
on allait au chant avec les parents les
frères et soeurs
on était vraiment à l'ipp épris de
liberté négociations même parfois du
favre de bois les huitièmes que nous
avons grandi pour avoir un peu de sous
pour nous mêmes
on venait de parler de l'éducation
financière
il faut être autonome mais rassurez vous
acceptez sans complexe de consignes
on était déjà conscients de cette
célèbre phrase de la vidéo et les peaux
qui dit il un sens c'est d'avoir honte
de ce qui est profitable
mais également à cette époque encore
jeunes écoliers que j'avais fait un rêve
dans lequel j'étais dans un engin
spatial qui atterrit sur la lune et tout
ce dont je me rappelle aujourd'hui de ce
rêve c'est une grande sensation d'avoir
accompli quelque chose de grand
mais aussi évidemment ce grand
tremblement occasionné pas
l'atterrissage de l'engin
et durant toute ma vie j'ai gardé mois
morere et j'essaie de m'en rapprocher
chaque jour que le bon dieu fait
un peu plus tard à l'université j'ai
découvert ma passion pour l'élever
technologie de commande pays
résigné à 4 donc littéraire la poursuite
de cette passion m'a permis de rentrer à
la nasa marshall space flight center
le département de la nasa qui va envoyer
en 2004 les astronautes de la mission
artemis humains sur la lune et un peu
plus tard sur mars
[Applaudissements]
en effet
la nasa utilisent les données satellites
et beaucoup d'autres technologies
géospatiales pour proposer des solutions
et trouver des solutions en tête aux
plus grands défis de notre époque et ce
soit dans l'agriculture la gestion des
ressources naturelles la gestion des
risques de catastrophes
et beaucoup d'autres défini ce qui était
un peu surprenant pour moi c'est que à
la nasa en parle beaucoup d'agriculture
et comme par hasard le slogan du
département où j'ai terme est connecté
l'espace au village
c'est cette photo
un exemple de cette application
nous voyons
le fleuve au cube en gros il sépare la
namibie de l'angola
du côté namibien il est cultivé du maïs
du blé
et l'adolescente
doit être utilisé pour prédire les
récoltes par exemple mais aussi pour
donner des indicateurs sur les parties
des centres qui ont le plus besoin
d'apports en aurons d'autres nutriments
l'analyse des données satellites vont
permettre également de planifier les
récoltes
10 sur les planches ou impôts de suivre
la croissance des cultures les banques
et assurances
pour financer des projets agricoles peut
utiliser les données satellites afin de
trouver des indicateurs climatiques
passés ou présents sur les zones
d'implémentation des projets agricoles
un autre secteur qui utilise beaucoup
les technologies géospatiales et celui
de la défense
mais moi je ne suis pas armé quand fin
de la défense qu'elle soit aussi les
catastrophes naturelles comme les
inondations et feuillus les feux de
végétation
les vents violents mais aussi les
paupières me
l'analyse de données satellites permet
le pouvoir fait des registres des gants
zones comme les frontières les eaux
côtières mais aussi les zones éloignées
et les a reçus d'imagerie permet
également
de pouvoir trouver des indicateurs
sur les évènements inattendus comme les
menaces physiques ou biologiques
passe rien on a fire récemment à saly
été ravagés par les feux et des données
satellites ont été utilisés pour venir à
bout de ce désastre
et pour ce faire les satellites qui
mesurent la vitesse et la direction du
vent ont été déployés justement pour
contrôler et suivre le comportement du
feu afin de prendre les meilleures
décisions
ce que je viens de dire c'est bien beau
mais quand vous êtes africain quand vous
êtes en afrique quand vous l'utilisez ce
genre de technologie vous ne l'êtes
développe pas forcément vous subissez et
que qui est disponible ce qu'on vous
apporte
avec ses comptes très bien sûr
la décidé de crier africains de dios
pêcheurs intelligence a adouci
pour atténuer cette situation
notre mission est de justement à
utiliser les technologies géospatiales
combiné avec l'analyse de données à
grande échelle
vous proposez des solutions dans le
domaine de l'agriculture
le domaine de gestion des risques de
catastrophes la défense l'économie bleus
et d'autre
serment
quand même chaud à 2019 nous avions fait
venir au togo
une équipe de la nasa or justement
former les acteurs du gouvernement sur
l'usagé des données satellites dans
l'agriculture la gestion des forêts mais
aussi les défis liés à l'eau
et c'était 1 à succion du gouvernement
togolais qui ont participé et l agence
nationale de protection civile
le ministère de la défense nationale le
ministère de l'environnement le minsep
l'agriculture la croix rouge togolaise
et beaucoup d'autres organisations
les récemment a pour credo les données
et la technologie doivent être au
service de l'humain c'est pourquoi
justement aujourd'hui nous sommes un
prévu d'utiliser nos technologies pour
accompagner l'unicef et la direction
générale de la protection de l'enfance à
être plus efficaces dans l'intervention
la chaîne de protection des enfants nous
développons pour eux en fait les outils
technologiques et intègre usages et
l'analyse des données
décembre 2019
nous étions danao national university
dont le laboratoire de technologie
spatiale a lancé le premier satellite
gagne 1 le ghana sa toile nous avions
signé un accord de partenariat avec
itunes university il nous accompagne
dans la formation
la fabrication et le lancement du
premier satellite au mollet le togo sa
toile
la mission de tous vos sites web elle de
faire le monitoring de l'agriculture et
de l'environnement
tout cela n'est pas sans défis mais nous
semble très content nous sommes très
heureux
de ce qui a encore des gens qui croient
au zénith au mollet ces gens parmi
lesquels le célèbre auteur de bande
dessinée
après pauline autrement dit
je cite
entendant les etats-unis ont envoyé une
mission sur la lune
dans ces camps spontanés le togo enverra
une mission une marque
et continuer dit ceci peut prendre la
forme d'une prophétie il ya toutes les
chances de se réaliser
une moto volée nous mettons à travailler
dur pour cela
et moi je vous dis j'espère que c'est
pas le temps - demont fusée
moi je vous dis
n'ai jamais peur mais vraiment jamais
n'ai jamais peur de porter des ambitions
beaucoup plus grande que vous
n'ayez jamais peur d'échouer
parce que vous savez quoi
juste moi vous risquez de réussir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]